hi there here i am again
korean challenge and today i want to
talk about
books okay
uh remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe to my channel you know
that i do a lot of my learning on my
ipad or on my computer using link i find
resources on the internet podcasts radio
stations all kinds of content that i can
import in addition to what we already
have at link however i do like books
one of the problems with korean is if i
pick up a korean book with no help no
link no access to dictionaries it's
still too difficult for me to read
whereas i found at a much earlier stage
in say czech or polish
i could just simply pick up a book even
in russian
although the comfort of reading in the
the writing system that you're most
familiar with shouldn't be
underestimated it helps a lot okay so
hangul to me is still relatively you
know less familiar
however
uh i like buying books i like reading
books and when i visited korea in
1976
i also like going to bookstores and
there i bought a book
on korean history and of course i could
because i could read chinese i could see
that it was
i presume that is
hang washer daiya
okay
and i thought because there's so many
characters so many chinese hanja in this
book that i could read it in fact i
couldn't because i couldn't make out
what was written between the characters
now i've
put enough effort into my uh korean that
not only do i know the words between the
characters but i know how to pronounce
the characters
korean style
more or less so i've now started back
into reading this book i'm going to pong
spring palm springs tomorrow flying so
i'll be able to read this on the
airplane and i'm going to devote myself
spend a fair amount of time reading
about korean history in korean with the
characters pronouncing them
korean
and i think that's going to just bring
in a different element
of engagement with the language that's
going to help me
and
so there you have it so i bought this
book i think i was in korea in 1976. uh
this was published in 1973 it says
um and here you are now
1973 whatever it is 40 some odd years
later i'm finally reading the book
so buy books you never know when they're
going to be
useful to you or enjoyable which is
often the same thing okay bye for now